Santa Cruz la región más próspera de
Bolivia cumple su sexto día de paro
indefinido exigiendo al gobierno de Luis
Arce la realización del censo de
población y vivienda el año 2023 y no el
2024 como pretende el poder ejecutivo
los dirigentes de Santa Cruz pretenden
que antes de las elecciones de 2025 con
base en estos resultados del censo se
realiza un nuevo reparto de recursos
pues la ciudad de Santa Cruz ha sido
receptora de migración en los últimos
años y por otro lado también buscan que
se haga una redistribución de escaños
parlamentarios pues consideran que les
corresponden más por tener más población
la medida de presión se realiza en medio
de alta tensión Pues los sectores que
apoyan al gobierno de Luis Arce han
instalado un bloqueo en las carreteras
en torno a la ciudad de Santa Cruz para
impedir el ingreso o la salida de
alimentos o de cualquier otro producto
es una especie de cerco que según los
dirigentes de Santa Cruz pretende
asfixiar y castigar a la ciudadanía en
paralelo el gobierno ha decretado la
suspensión de las exportaciones de
productos de Santa Cruz entre ellos el
azúcar la carne la soya y sus derivados
lo que ha sido rechazado por el sector
empresarial pues considera que esta
medida perjudica todo el país y no
solamente a unos cuantos empresarios de
Santa Cruz el conflicto también ha
escalado a otras regiones por ejemplo se
han registrado enfrentamientos en las
últimas horas en los departamentos de la
paz y tarija exigiendo también la
realización del censo de población y
vivienda para el año 2023